[Music]
when thousands of blue-collar workers
showed up in ottawa several weeks ago to
protest the tyranny being imposed
against them the prime minister of
canada refused to meet with them or to
speak to them instead he fled the city
and then from his bunker he called the
truckers nazis when they still didn't
leave the city justin trudeau suspended
democracy and declared canada a
dictatorship
the federal government
has invoked the emergencies act
to supplement provincial and territorial
capacity to address the blockades
and occupations the emergencies act will
be used to strengthen and support law
enforcement agencies
at all levels across the country
this is about keeping canadians safe
protecting people's jobs
and restoring confidence in our
institutions
so let's be clear this is a defining
moment in the history of canada in the
history of the english-speaking west the
emergencies act is martial law
it has never been invoked in the history
of that country now by law the
emergencies act is allowed only in
emergencies in quote urgent and critical
situations that seriously endanger the
lives health or safety of canadians
what's happening now does not qualify
what's happening in canada now is not an
emergency here's what it looked like
this weekend
[Music]
[Music]
according to justin trudeau
everyone you saw in that tape is a
terrorist even the kids in their bouncy
castles justin trudeau has unilaterally
revoked their civil liberties and
authorized men with automatic weapons to
haul them to jail trudeau was allowed
for the rest of this man for example
making food for the terrorists
you can receive a free meal irregardless
of what faith you're from what cast
creed religion doesn't matter it's about
the community kitchen we all eat as one
and humanity is equal
so
the seva concept
helping the community is what we're
practicing here today we're here
alongside the truckers in the fight for
freedom and we're doing our part from
the sick faith
so again all of these people can now be
arrested on site simply because of where
they're standing but being arrested is
the least of their problems an arrest
suggests bail you can get out of jail
you can't get out of the country justin
trudeau has just made
under martial law trudeau now has the
power to force banks to seize their bank
accounts and insurance companies to
cancel their insurance that means they
can't actually live in canada anymore
they are non-persons they're enemies of
the state and they will be crushed
at least one trucker knows exactly
what's coming he has seen him before he
came to canada from nikolai ceausescu's
romania
why did only people meant to vote
why 100 people
180 or 200 people to decide your life
for my or another let's let the canadian
people together
no it's all corrupt too all those people
holding
when when some people they decide your
life like 300 people they decide your
life when you are 30 million yeah
let us vote
so it is it an overstatement to compare
what is happening in canada right now to
what happens in a stalinist dictatorship
well the slogans are different in the
eastern bloc they used to talk about
solidarity in canada they talk about
diversity
but the repression is similar today
canada's deputy prime minister by the
way as a former american journalist
maybe not surprisingly announced that
going forward justin trudeau will
regulate all crowd funding and
cryptocurrency under the terrorist
financing act
really so justin trudeau is now in
charge of all of your finances
he's in charge of cryptocurrency how is
that how does that work and on what
justification
and if that wasn't clear enough
trudeau's minority government
unilaterally just sent another half a
billion dollars to the authoritarian
state of ukraine
where the head of the rival political
party is now under arrest and where
opposition media has been banned
that's the country they're now in
solidarity with you can see where this
is going in fact it's already there
i'm steve ducey i'm brian kilmeade and
i'm ainslie earhart and click here to
subscribe to the fox news youtube page
to catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis